[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend der
Kanzler hat einen Machtwort gesprochen
basta wenn es denn so einfach wäre der
Kanzler oder die Kanzlerin ist zwar mit
der viel zitierten Richtlinienkompetenz
ausgestattet aber im Grundgesetz steht
ja auch dass Minister Ministerinnen für
ihre Ressorts selbst zuständig sind
insofern gibt es da keine eindeutige
Gebrauchsanweisung für öffentliche
Machtworte aus denen schnell
grundsätzliche macht Fragen werden
können wenn ein Kanzler sich dann nicht
durchsetzt das Risiko gehen Kanzler im
Zweifelsfälle nur ein wenn andernfalls
die Handlungsfähigkeit der Regierung auf
dem Spiel steht die Situation war hier
wohl gegeben FDP und Grüne hatten sich
in der Atomfrage ja geradezu auswegslos
ineinander verbissen Andreas Huppert
über das kanzlerbuster und die
Reaktionen darauf
bis vor gut vier Stunden war das hier
ein Auslaufmodell das Kernkraftwerk
Emsland in Niedersachsen am 31.12 sollte
Schluss sein nachdem hier 34 Jahre lang
Strom produziert wurde so steht es im
Atomgesetz jetzt erlebt der Meile offen
Beine Lebenszeit sprich
Laufzeitverlängerung bis in den April 23
möglich geworden ist das Ganze weil Olaf
Scholz von seiner Richtlinienkompetenz
Gebrauch gemacht hat wieder besagt nach
Artikel 65 Grundgesetz bestimmt der
Bundeskanzler die Richtlinien der
Politik und trägt hierfür die
Verantwortung
Scholz hat ein Machtwort gesprochen im
nicht enden wollen den Streit zwischen
FDP und Grünen über AKW-Laufzeiten
während er vor dem Kanzleramt den
spanischen König empfängt arbeiten die
Beamten im Kanzleramt seine schriftliche
Erklärung aus darin heißt es es wird
eine gesetzliche Grundlage geschaffen um
den Leistungsbetrieb der Kernkraftwerke
Isar 2 Neckarwestheim 2 sowie Emsland
über den
31.12.2022 hinaus bis längstens
15.04.2023 zu ermöglichen das
Kernkraftwerk Emsland ist eines der
sichersten eines der effizientesten der
Welt und genau das vom Netz zu nehmen
wäre sicherlich nicht klug gewesen und
vor dem Hintergrund begrüße ich die
Entscheidung die der Kanzler für die
Bundesregierung getroffen hat ja dass
die FDP es gut heißt ist klar die
Liberalen Wolken gab es 2024 verlängern
doch was ist mit den Grünen die hatten
erst am Wochenende auf ihrem Parteitag
rote Linien gezogen die beiden
süddeutschen AKW ja aber Emsland auf gar
keinen Fall und jetzt
ich halte das ehrlich gesagt für
schlechten Stil mit so einer basta
Politik auch die Beschlüsse des gerade
getroffenen Parteitags einfach so zu
ignorieren von Koalitionspartner und wir
brauchen eine Debatte darüber und keine
basta Politik das klingt nach weiterem
Zoff in der Ampel 20 Uhr heute Abend
krisenfraktionssitzung der Grünen wie
umgehen mit diskanzlers Machtwort man
nehme es erstmal zur Kenntnis das tut
auch die CDU
Opposition
mit dem Machtwort ist das Problem der
Mondpreise und der Stromausfälle nicht
gelöst er hilft damit vielleicht der
Ampel aber nicht im Land bei der SPD
sehen Sie das Kanzler Machtwort als
salomonische Lösung im ampelkonflikt als
Mittelweg aus der Energiekrise
wir verlängern jetzt die Laufzeit im
streckbetrieb bis in den April nächsten
Jahres hinein aber wir machen keine
Rolle rückwärts ins atomenergiezeitalter
und ich glaube das ist ein gerechter
Interessenausgleich vor gut einer halben
Stunde ein erstes Statement der Grünen
Parteispitze nach der
krisenfraktionssitzung Olaf Scholz hat
jetzt schon seine richtigen Kompetenz
Gebrauch gemacht was absolut klar ist es
werden keine neuen Brennstäbe beschafft
es gibt keinen Laufzeitverlängerung und
alle deutschen AKWs werden damit bis zum
spätesten 15.4 vom Netz gehen der Thomas
stieg kommt das AKW Emsland ist
Zankapfel in der Koalition Kanzler
Scholz hat gesprochen ein Machtwort das
den ampelstreit in Sachen Atomlaufzeiten
endgültig beilegen soll mal schauen ob
es gelingt
in Berlin ein Machtwort dass das schien
auch bitter nötig oder das war nötig und
das war überfällig denn das lange nicht
entscheiden das Kanzlers hat den beiden
Koalitionspartnern ja erst die Zeit und
auch den politischen Raum gegeben sich
in ihren Positionen einzugraben bis hin
ja zum Parteitagsbeschluss der Grünen
und auch parlamentarisch kommt es
Kanzler Machtwort quasi im letzten
Moment in die Betreiber brauchen
dringend Klarheit zur Vorbereitung des
Weiterbetriebs und diese Sitzungswoche
des Parlaments ist eigentlich die letzte
Chance dass
Atomausstiegsgesetz zu ändern denn
ansonsten gäbe es keine gesetzliche
Möglichkeiten AKW über den 31.12
hinauslaufen zu lassen dann haben wir es
eben gesehen die FDP demonstriert
Zufriedenheit für die Grünen hingegen
scheint das schwer zu schlucken zu sein
ja ich glaube im Moment übertreiben
beide Parteien eher aus strategischen
Gründen ihre jeweilige Betroffenheit vom
Kanzler Machtwort die FDP zeigt sich
deutlich zufriedener als sie eigentlich
Anlass hätte denn sie bekommt im Grunde
ja nur dreieinhalb Monate zusätzliche
Laufzeit für das AKW Emsland und nicht
wie eigentlich gefordert alle drei
Kraftwerke bis nach dem Winter 23 24 und
neue Brennstäbe zu kaufen und die Grünen
sind natürlich mächtig aufgeraut weil
sie sich gerade erst auf den Parteitag
auf zwei AKW festgelegt hatten und jetzt
schreibt ihnen der Kanzler etwas anderes
vor Jürgen Trittin hattens hat uns
gerade erst gesagt die Grundlage für die
Zusammenarbeit in der Ampel sei jetzt
schwer erschüttert aber de facto ist es
Machtwort nah an der grünen Position
Ausstieg spätestens 15 April 23
politisch können damit eigentlich alle
irgendwie Leben bleibt aber die
vielleicht ja noch wichtigere Frage ob
das Land am Ende genug Energie für den
Winter 23 24 hat
Dankeschön Theo für die Einschätzung
während Deutschland versucht Lösungen
für seine Energieprobleme zu finden
durch litten die Ukrainer heute einen
neuen schrecklichen Tag
Kiew war erneut Ziel massiver Angriffe
diesmal vor allem mit kampfdrohen
mutmaßlich geliefert von Iran Putins
Verbündete zu diesen Drohnen und was sie
für das Kriegsgeschehen bedeuten gleich
noch ein Gespräch mit einer Expertin und
wie Europa darauf reagieren sollte habe
ich bundesaußenministerin baerbock
gefragt zunächst aber berichtet unsere
Porter da Sansa D aus Kiew
Kiew im Morgengrauen im Zentrum der
Stadt feuert die ukrainische Luftabwehr
auf russische Kampfdrohnen die
Sicherheitskräfte wissen dass die
kampfdrohne in wenigen Sekunden
einschlagen wird es sind gewehrsalben es
ist ein verzweifelter letzter Versuch zu
Verteidigung
eine der heutigen Drohnen hat ein
Wohnhaus getroffen vier Menschen haben
diesen Montagmorgen nicht überlebt unter
ihnen ein junges Paar die Frau war im
sechsten Monat schwanger 19 Menschen
konnten aus den Trümmern gerettet werden
wir bieten wir bieten unsere Partner wir
brauchen wir brauchen moderne
Verteidigungswaffen und dieses Systeme
an direktsystemen welche Schutz unserer
Burge weil die heute heute die
wichtigste die wichtigste Frage
Sicherheit für jede in unserer Stadt in
unser Land Russland setzt verstärkt
sogenannte Kamikaze Drohnen ein sie
nähern sich in großer Höhe schalten den
Antrieb ab und stürzen auf ihr Ziel die
Drohnen sind kaum mehr steuerbar und
ungenau der heutige Angriff galt dem
Heizkraftwerk auf der anderen
Straßenseite traf aber das Wohnhaus
den Menschen bleibt bei Luftalarm nur
eins der Gang in den nächsten
schutzpunkte
hier in der Tiefgarage um die Ecke hat
sich eine Schicksalsgemeinschaft
eingefunden
gemeinsames warten auf Entwarnung André
ist it-programmierer für amerikanische
Firmen er wissen nie wie er ihnen sein
Leben unter Luftangriffen in Kiew
erklären soll und sie fragen ihn oft
sagte
wir haben alles gehört was heute
geschehen ist du hast dann für einige
Minuten Angst aber danach nach ungefähr
30 Minuten gehst du wieder auf die
Straße und du siehst so viele Menschen
und du versuchst dein normales Leben
wieder weiterzuführen
again trotz der Furcht vor einer
gespenstigen Waffe russland hat es auf
die Infrastruktur der Ukraine abgesehen
und die Menschen hier müssen mit
weiteren Angriffen rechnen
ja was hat es mit diesen Kampfdrohnen
auf sich die heute wieder so viel
Schrecken verbreiteten das möchte ich
eine ausgewiesene Expertin auf diesem
Gebiet Fragen Ulrike Franke
Sicherheitsexpertin vom European Council
und Foren relations und ihr
Spezialgebiet sind neue
kriegstechnologien insbesondere Drohnen
guten Abend Frau Franke einen schönen
guten Abend diese Drohnen nennt man ja
diese iranischen die heute
über Kiew wieder auftauchten und so viel
Leid verursachten nennt man ja auch
kamikazedonen können Sie uns etwas näher
erklären wie das funktioniert was ist
damit auf sich hat
ja in der Tat also eigentlich sind diese
drohnensysteme gar keine wirkliche
Drohnen insofern als dass sie nicht
wiederverwertbar sind und deswegen
spricht man von
kamikazedonen oder auch sogenannter
herumlungernder Munition das sind
Systeme die werden in die Luft
geschossen können da eine Zeit lang
Kreisen können eine gewisse Reichweite
fliegen und stürzen sich dann auf ihr
Ziel und explodierend mit diesen Ziel
soll heißen sie sind eben nur einmal
verwertbar und können wie wir jetzt
gesehen haben von von Russland weit
entfernt von den Frontlinien eingesetzt
werden und der Terror verbreiten und das
hat meines Erachtens eigentlich den
größten Einfluss hier dieser Tage diese
Verbreitung des Terrors mit diesen
einmal verwendbaren Drohnen weil sie
sich eben auch gegen zivile Ziele
richten und weil sie ja von überall
herzukommen scheinen und wir aus dem
Nichts auftauchen
ja in der Tat der Punkt ist dass diese
Systeme von Trucks also von LKWs
gestartet werden können deswegen sind
sie sehr verlegefähig und können
überall mehr oder minder eingesetzt
werden und sie haben eine erstaunlich
weiter Reichweite die sie iranischen
Systeme und daher ist Russland eben in
der Lage auch weit entfernt von den
Frontlinien anzugreifen und deswegen
auch dieses Gefühl zu verbreiten dass
die Ukraine die Ukraine nirgendwo mehr
sicher sind und das hat sicherlich einen
psychologischen Einfluss macht im
übrigen natürlich auch die Bekämpfung
dieser Systeme schwieriger weil man ja
überall gleichzeitig gucken muss und das
bindet Kräfte und ist auch praktisch
einfach eigentlich so nicht nicht
wirklich möglich sie sagen diese
Bedrohungen sich dagegen zu wehren das
ist schwierig gibt es denn überhaupt
schon Systeme bei denen man weiß dass
die funktionieren ist jetzt viel die
Rede davon Mensch wir Deutschen wir
haben doch ihre C so heißt sein
Luftverteidigungssystem geliefert andere
werden genannt aber so einfach scheint
es nicht zu sein oder
ja ich sag immer drohnenabwehr ist
schwierig und einfach gleichzeitig also
einfach insofern als das Drohnen in der
Regel relativ langsam fliegen relativ
niedrig fliegen die sind auch nicht
besonders geschützt oder versteckt also
Tarnkappen Technik ist da in der Regel
kein großes Thema es sollte also einfach
sein sie vom Himmel zu holen
gleichzeitig ist es aber schwierig denn
man muss diese Systeme entdecken und
zwar rechtzeitig entdecken und das ob
der Tatsache dass die meisten
Radarsysteme einfach nicht dafür gebaut
sind diese kleinen Drohnen zu entdecken
dann gibt es auch noch ganz verschiedene
Systeme wir reden jetzt gerade über ein
System was heute die letzten Tage in der
Ukraine viel eingesetzt wurde aber der
Iran hat zum Beispiel auch andere Bohnen
geliefert also auch das ist relativ
schwierig und dann muss man eben ja im
richtigen Moment vor Ort sein das ganze
soll noch kosteneffizient sein denn man
will ja nicht quasi mit Kanonen auf
Spatzen schießen also diese Drohnen
Kosten vielleicht mehrere zehntausend
Euro oder Dollar das ist jetzt nicht so
viel wie viele Abwehr und das macht es
wiederum schwierig und es ist in der Tat
so dass die Ukraine ja Abwehrsysteme hat
und die Ukraine sagt auch dass sie
wirklich dutzende dieser Drohnen schon
abgeschossen hat sehr erfolgreich das
ist recht beeindruckend und da kann man
alles mögliche verwenden also was ich
jetzt gesehen habe heute waren
schultergestützte Systeme sogenannte
manpads der Gepard scheint wohl auch zum
Einsatz gekommen zu sein ihres Tier habe
ich jetzt noch nicht gehört das könnte
vielleicht etwas überdimensioniert sein
S300 also es gibt verschiedene
Abwehrsysteme aber es ist halt doch
nicht so einfach und wenn eine oder
mehrere durchkommen können sie eben
Schaden anrichten Frau Franke danke für
die Expertise und die Einordnung
das Gespräch haben wir vor einer Stunde
geführt unter dem Eindruck der
Geschehnisse in Kiew fuhren die
EU-Außenminister heute morgen zu ihrem
Treffen in Luxemburg während ihr
ukrainischer Kollege noch im
Luftschutzkeller saß was tun und der
Ukraine auch gegen solche Angriffe zu
helfen wie umgehen mit dem Regime in
Iran das offenbar tödliche Waffen in
einem Angriffskrieg liefert wäre das
zugleich die eigene Bevölkerung
terrorisiert
dieser Krieg ist für die Europäer in
vieler Hinsicht eine Zeitenwende Isabel
Schäfers berichtet ein Kanzler der auf
die Macht der Bilder setzt Olaf Scholz
besucht eine gefechtsübung
auf dem Truppenübungsplatz Bergen fährt
die Bundeswehr auf Panzer Eurofighter
alles nur zu Demonstrationszwecken aber
Olaf Scholz lässt keinen Zweifel die
Situation sei ernst
für mich ist das sehr beeindruckend aber
auch einen Auftrag genau das zu tun was
wir uns jetzt vorgenommen haben für
unser Land nämlich sicherzustellen dass
die Bundeswehr gut ausgestattet ist dass
Sie Ihre Aufträge wahrnehmen kann und
ganz besonders den wichtigen und wieder
neu wichtig gewordenen Auftrag der
Landes- und bündnisverteidigung wieder
wichtig geworden durch den russischen
Angriff auf die Ukraine die soll weiter
mit allen Mitteln unterstützt werden die
EU-Außenminister haben heute beschlossen
15.000 ukrainische Soldaten sollen in
der EU ausgebildet werden zunächst vor
allem in Polen und Deutschland wir
werden jetzt natürlich mit den Ukrainern
zusammen der ukrainische Außenminister
ist ja heute hier auch digital
zugeschaltet heute aber auch in den
nächsten Wochen und Monaten darüber
sprechen wie viele das genau zu welchem
Zeitpunkt sein werden weil auch wieder
hier so eine Ausbildung ist ja kein
Selbstzweck sondern soll die Ukraine
bestmöglich bei ihrem
Selbstverteidigungsrecht unterstützen
mehrere auß Minister twitterten über den
Austausch mit ihrem ukrainischen
Kollegen sichtlich bewegt denn der war
zugeschaltet aus einem Schutzbunker
russland hat heute unter anderem Kiew
erneut mit Raketen und Drohnen
angegriffen letztere womöglich von Iran
geliefert
deshalb ist nun die Zeit gekommen
Sanktionen gegen Iran zu verhängen weil
sie Waffen an Russland liefern
das wäre auch ein Signal an die anderen
Länder bei denen Russland derzeit um
militärische Unterstützung bittet
wird
wir werden nach konkreten beweisen einer
iranischen Beteiligung suchen der Iran
streitet das bisher ab
wegen der anhaltenden Gewalt gegen
protestieren der in Iran haben die
Außenminister heute bereits neue
Sanktionen beschlossen 15 regierungsnah
Einzelpersonen und Organisationen werden
mit einreisesperren belegt ihre Vermögen
in der EU eingefroren darunter Vertreter
der sogenannten Sittenpolizei ich glaube
die allmächtigen in im Iran müssen mal
auf den Kalender schauen und Sie sehen
dass wir 2022 sind die Menschen wollen
nicht mehr eingesperrt sind darum muss
die Europäische Union jetzt diesen
ersten Schritt machen ist das was wir
tun können aber ich fürchte das nicht
der letzte
man werde die Situation in Iran
beobachten weitere Sanktionen nicht
ausgeschlossen
und Außenministerin bärburg ist uns
zugeschaltet guten Abend Frau bärburg
schönen guten Abend ihr ukrainischer
Kollege Kollege hat aus dem
Luftschutzkeller heute getwittert und
sich an die europäischen Außenminister
gewandt und gesagt wir werden hier von
iranischen Drohnen beschossen ihr müsst
was tun ihr müsst Sanktionen gegen Iran
erheben wie reagieren die Europäer
darauf
also das zeigt wie wirklich dramatisch
die Lage ist er hat da nicht nur raus
getwittert sondern ich glaube zum ersten
Mal wahrscheinlich in der EU-Geschichte
hat ein Außenminister mit uns eine
Videoschalte gehabt direkt aus dem
Bombenkeller hinaus in den europäischen
Ratsaal hinein das macht deutlich in was
für einer Situation wir sind nämlich das
der Frieden in Europa im wahrsten Sinne
des Wortes so angegriffen wird dass der
ukrainische Außenminister in Sicherheit
gebracht werden muss und deswegen haben
wir im Rat auch in dieser schalte dann
ihm gegenüber deutlich gemacht natürlich
werden wir weiterhin alles dafür tun
dass die Ukraine sich verteidigen kann
die iranischen Drohnen die Sie
angesprochen haben zeigen ja was diese
beiden Länder was diesen beiden Regime
dass die nicht nur im geistebrüder sind
sondern dass sie sich gegenseitig
unterstützen mit Waffenlieferung
unterstützen und deswegen ist unsere
eine Antwort mit Blick auf die
furchtbare Lage in Iran selber das war
ein Sanktionspaket auf den Weg gebracht
haben aber ich habe heute auch schon im
Rat dann angekündigt dass aus meiner
Sicht auch mit Blick auf diese drohen
Lieferung aus Iran nach Russland eben
ein weiteres Sanktionspaket gegenüber
dem iranischen Regime folgen muss also
es gibt bei den EU-Außenminister oder
den EU-Regierungen keine Zweifel dass es
sich um iranische Drohnen handelt die
Iraner bezweifeln das ja oder die Iraner
dementieren das ja aber auch in der
wissenschaftlichen Gemeinschaft gibt es
ja überhaupt keinen Zweifel daran also
bei Ihnen auch nicht wir müssen das
natürlich wir sind ja zum Glück eine
Demokratie und wir sind in einem
Rechtsstaat und deswegen müssen wir
solche sanktionspakete rechtlich so
immer formulieren dass das auch vor
Gerichten Bestand hat ich kriege ja auch
immer wieder Fragen von denjenigen aus
dem Irani sagen Mensch warum könnt ihr
das nicht alles schneller machen wo ich
sage es muss alles natürlich rechtlich
sauber sein deswegen können wir das
Sanktionspaket das weitere für den Iran
auch heute konnten wir äußern dass wir
das wollen aber es muss jetzt alles
entsprechend vorbereitet werden genau
für den Punkt den Sie angesprochen haben
dass auch vollkommen klar ist aber ich
meine die Kamikaze drohen die da
abgeschossen worden sind und die ja auch
in Kiew eingeschlagen sind da ist doch
sehr sehr deutlich woher sie kommen gibt
es denn überhaupt noch Möglichkeiten
Iran groß zu sanktionieren also Sie
haben ja zum Beispiel heute auch
beschlossen dass es Sanktionen geben
wird gegen die Sittenpolizei die
zeitgleich ja im Iran die
Protestbewegung so brutal niederschlägt
aber da ist dann auch nicht mehr viel
Vermögen einfrieren nicht einreisen das
wird jetzt ein solches Regime das mit
einem revolutionären Bewegung kämpft
kaum beeindrucken und ansonsten gibt es
ja schon unheimlich viele Sanktionen
gegenüber Iran bringt das eigentlich
noch was
ja es gibt bereits vier sanktionssysteme
zum Teil mit Blick auf
Menschenrechtsverletzungen auch aus dem
Jahr 2019
andere Sanktionen mit Blick auf die
nukleare Anreicherung aber es ist
wichtig dass wir jetzt auch mit Blick
auf diese furchtbaren Niederschlagung
die in Iran in den letzten Wochen wir
alle gesehen haben und ja kaum zu
ertragen sind wir sind ja als zwei
Frauen im Fernsehen geschaltet sowas
wäre Iran ja überhaupt nicht möglich
dass wir wie wir wollen uns miteinander
unterhalten können dass wir einfach Frau
sein können und deswegen ist es wichtig
dass wir mit diesem Sanktionspaket heute
speziell auf diejenigen die
verantwortlich sind dafür dass Frauen
umgebracht worden sind dass Teenager
verhaftet werden vergewaltigt werden
dass diese Person die dafür
verantwortlich sind die Akteure der
Sittenpolizei polizeischiffes vor Ort
aber auch Minister in dieser Regierung
dass die nicht mehr in die Europäische
Union einreisen können dass ihre Gelder
eingefroren werden weil das darf man
auch nicht nicht vergessen dieses System
ist ja nicht nur mit voller Brutalität
gegenüber seiner eigenen Bevölkerung in
den letzten Wochen sondern in den
letzten Jahrzehnten bereits vorgegangen
und hat sich zugleich an seiner eigenen
Bevölkerung massiv bereichert das heißt
es liegen eben solche Gelder im Zweifel
auch auf europäischen Bankkonten und
dass die Verantwortlichen für diese
Brutalität darauf keinen Zugriff mehr
haben das stellen wir mit diesem
weiteren Sanktionspaket heute sicher
bleibt aber trotzdem die Frage ob das
das iranische ob das das iranische
Regime sonderlich beeindrucken wird wenn
jetzt Vermögen eingefroren werden man
verdient ja offenbar hervorragend Geld
indem man Kampfdrohnen nach Russland
verkauft
genau deswegen wollen wir da auch
Sanktionen drauflegen aber wie sie sagen
das wird im Zweifel autoritäre Regime
nicht davon abbringen das sehen wir auch
mit Blick auf Russland aber es macht
deutlich die Welt schaut eben nicht weg
und wenn wir das gemeinsam tun als
Weltgemeinschaft dann hat es eben auch
Auswirkungen und ich glaube schon dass
es vor einzelne Akteure in solchen
Regime schon eine Bedeutung hat ob im
Zweifel auch ihre Familie Mitglieder in
Europa studieren können ob sie hier vor
Ort einfach mal so shoppen gehen können
oder nicht und es macht deutlich wir
stehen auf der Seite derjenigen die so
brutal angegriffen werden wir stehen auf
Seite der Menschenrechte auf der Seite
der Frauen und gerade die iranischen
Frauen machen ja immer wieder deutlich
wie wichtig es für sie ist dass wir
unsere Stimme erheben Frau Leben
Freiheit das ist was Sie vor Ort
skandieren und das ist was wir als
Europäische Außenminister zumindest auch
zurückgeben können dass wir die Freiheit
das Leben und das Frau sein schützen und
die zur Rechenschaft ziehen die für
Morde verantwortlich sind Frau Berger
vielen Dank für das Gespräch danke
ebenso alles Gute
das Interview haben wir aus Termin
Gründen am frühen Abend aufgezeichnet
als auch noch nicht klar war dass der
Kanzler der Atomfrage von seiner
Richtlinienkompetenz Gebrauch machen
würde jetzt die Nachrichten zunächst
nach großbritannienheim der ist die
Regierung für ein ziemlich in Turbulenz
ja die Regierung von Premierministerin
Trust vollzieht bei ihren Steuerplänen
eine Kehrtwende der neue Finanzminister
Hand nahm so gut wie alle angekündigten
Steuer Erleichterungen zurück die
mögliche Finanzierung durch Schulden
hatte Turbulenzen an den Finanzmärkten
und einen Kursrutsch des britischen
Pfunds ausgelöst
bei den Vereinten Nationen ist ein neuer
menschenrechtskommissar im Amt der
Völkerrechtler Volker Turk der
57-Jährige Österreicher ist seit mehr
als 30 Jahren für die UNO tätig zuletzt
in der Führungsriege um Generalsekretär
uterisch Türk folgt auf die Chilenen
Michele bacelett die nicht für eine
zweite Amtszeit kandidierte
Schweden hat nach acht Jahren
sozialdemokratischer Führung seit heute
einen konservativen Regierungschef der
neue Ministerpräsident Ulf Christa schon
wurde vom Parlament mit knapper Mehrheit
gewählt und war dabei auf die Stimme in
der rechtspopulistischen
Schwedendemokraten angewiesen diese
gehören zwar nicht der
Minderheitsregierung Christus Schanz an
wollen das Dreierbündnis aus moderaten
Christdemokraten und liberalen aber
unterstützen
[Applaus]
bei Eurowings Deutschland hat diese neue
Woche mit dem Streik Aufruf der
Vereinigung Cockpit begonnen und somit
auch mit Flugausfällen sind da ein
kompromissansatz in Sicht oder wie soll
es in der Auseinandersetzung weitergehen
also bis gerade eben 21 Uhr hat das
Management von Eurowings der
Pilotenvereinigung Cockpit ein Ultimatum
gestellt ihr Angebot anzunehmen es blieb
ohne Resonanz Eurowings bietet den
Piloten 10 freie Tage mehr pro Jahr und
wöchentlich drei Stunden mehr Freizeit
schon zum zweiten mal in diesem Monat
streiken die Eurowings Piloten noch bis
Mittwoch sind etliche Flüge gestrichen
die Gewerkschaft Vereinigung Cockpit
fordert kürzere Arbeitszeiten längere
Ruhephasen und zusätzlich 14 freie Tage
pro Jahr auffallend ist dass es dieses
Mal nicht um mehr Geld sondern um mehr
Freizeit für die Piloten geht dieser
Streik kostet Eurowings täglich einen
zweistelligen Millionenbetrag erst
blieben die Flieger durch die
corona-pandemie am Boden und nun durch
wiederkehrende Streiks die Nachrichten
bei Eurowings schaden nicht nur
finanziell sie kratzen auch am Image der
Airline und des Mutterkonzerns Lufthansa
in
corona-shilfen finanziell gerettet hat
Lufthansa inzwischen längst alles
zurückbezahlt und fliegt wieder auf der
Erfolgsspur die Lufthansa-Aktie legt
heute ordentlich zu weil die Fluglinie
ihre Gewinnprognose deutlich angehoben
hat ein Plus von 1,6 Prozent ja ähnlich
viel konnte der DAX zum Wochenstart
zulegen am Ende schließt der bei
12.649 Punkten das Nachsehen bei diesen
erneuten Streiks haben vor allem auch
die Kunden Passagiere sind genervt dass
sie am Flughafen stranden und nicht am
Strand landen
jetzt vielen Dank
nach einer neuen Studie im Auftrag der
Kultusministerkonferenz sind bei
Viertklässlern die Kompetenzen in den
Fächern Deutsch und Mathematik weiter
zurückgegangen laut
Bundesbildungsministerin stark Watzinger
ist dieser Trend nicht erst seit der
corona-pandemie zu beobachten sondern
bereits seit zehn Jahren aktuell
verfehlen laut Studie bundesweit fast 19
Prozent den Mindeststandard beim Lesen
beim Rechnen sind es rund 22 Prozent bei
der Rechtschreibung und 30%
wie sehr der Umgang mit Sprache und die
Lust am Schreiben die eigene Identität
das Finden des eigenen Ichs prägen kann
zeigt der diesjährige Deutsche Buchpreis
der heute Abend in Frankfurt verliehen
wurde für das blutbuch so der Titel von
Kim de lorison ein Künstlername aber
keine Kunstfigur sondern ein Mensch der
in seinem Roman viel von der eigenen
Entwicklung erzählt und so
unkonventionell wie die Sprache des
Buches war auch die Dankesrede auf der
Preisverleihung
Kim de lorison rasiert sich in der
Dankesrede die Haare ab aus Solidarität
mit den Frauen im Iran und erhält dafür
stehenden Applaus
ich denke die Jury hat diesen Text auch
ausgewählt
um ein Zeichen zu setzen gegen den Hass
für die Liebe für den Kampf aller
Menschen die wegen ihres Körpers
unterdrückt werden
der Roman blutbuch wird ausgezeichnet
zum zweiten Mal geht der Deutsche
Buchpreis in die Schweiz erstmals an
eine non-binäre Person die sich also
keinem der herkömmlichen Geschlechter
zugehörig fühlt
das blutbuch hat uns fasziniert und
provoziert in seiner Radikalität es
findet mit einer großen
sprachenergie neue Formen Formen für
eine non binäre Geschlechtsidentität und
das trifft mitten ins Herz unseres
Zusammenlebens die erzählfigur in
blutbuch heißt Kim und ist weder Mann
noch Frau wie die Person die den Roman
geschrieben hat doch sind sie eins
biografisches und erdachtes verschmelzen
in einem Brief an die Großmutter die an
Demenz erkrankt ist es geht um
Erinnerungen an die Kindheit die
Traumata der eigenen Familie und die
Auseinandersetzung mit sich selbst und
dem eigenen Körper Kim de lorison
experimentiert dabei mit der Sprache mal
sanft und zurückhaltend mal drastisch
und klar
sechs Bücher schafften es bis in die
Schlussrunde allein dadurch erhalten Sie
alle besondere Aufmerksamkeit
Kim delorie Songs extravaganter Roman
hat sich durchgesetzt
en Klinge berichtete das was im
heute-journal und gleich nach dem Wetter
geht es mit dem montagskino weiter so
00:10
heute schnell Update uns gibt es morgen
wieder auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend das war heute wirklich
ungewöhnlich warm für Mitte Oktober mit
27 Grad hier an der Saale am Oberrhein
kletterten die Werte zum Teil über 25
Grad von Nordwesten ist jetzt eine
Kaltfront herangekommen und die
beschäftigt uns auch noch bis morgen
Abend sie zieht nämlich langsam weiter
in Richtung Tschechien und Österreich
die warme Luft wird damit so ein
bisschen abgedrängt aber dann übernimmt
bald ein hoch und das Wetter beruhigt
sich am Mittwoch wieder deutlich bei uns
heute Nacht also fällt Regen zwischen
der Ostseeküste und der Mosel hier im
alten Vorland bildet sich zum Teil
wieder dicker Nebel eher aufgelockert
ist es an der Nordseeküste unter den
dichteren Wolken in der Mitte sinken die
Temperaturen auf 14 bis 12 Grad an der
Nordsee sind es so 10 11 Grad hier im
Südosten geht es auf 9 bis 7 Grad runter
und morgen ist es dann eben nicht mehr
ganz so warm wie heute 15 Grad erwarten
uns an der Schlei und 24 Grad am
Oberrhein am Vormittag ist die Karlsruhe
schon etwas weiter im Südosten
angekommen dann regnet es zum Teil auch
mal kräftiger zwischen
Berlin-Brandenburg und Rheinland-Pfalz
nach Nebel kann sich hier im
Alpenvorland schön die Sonne zeigen und
eher aufgelockert bewölkt ist es an der
Küste bei Westwind nachmittags dreht der
Wind auf Nordwest und damit zieht die
Kaltfront weiter nach Südosten es kann
dann auch mal ein Gewitter dabei sein am
Mittwoch geht’s nach Nebel und
hochnehmen bei uns viel Sonnenschein
weil noch mit sehr milden 12 bis 20 Grad
am Donnerstag kommen von Westen neue
Regenwolken heran und die breiten sich
am Freitag weiter Richtung Norden und
Südosten aus guten Abend